une série mobile le nouveau jouet
d'andré frenette
au prix où les le bois il ya des gens
qui me demandent m me couper du monsieur
diouf dans la région de bathurst il
n'est pas le seul à s'être tourné vers
cette activité depuis la pandémie se
seraient 20 km probablement que je fais
dans mon 5,6
c'est au niveau des régions rurales à se
libérer ni des voisins arrête même le
voir pour lui poser des questions sur sa
nouvelle acquisition
vos magasins chercher un morceau de bois
s'apprête à lui c'est tout croche puis
on la seule chose qui nous vend c'est de
la cochonnerie notre bois nous autres
les shipyard et on sait ce qu'est le
problème au niveau de la qualité du bois
le bois d'isle of n'emporterait 9 fois
sur 10 sur les restes en tout pictures
in nous réserve
après avoir fait le plein de profits en
exploitant et exportant nos ressources
collectives
le groupe irving pour qui le premier
ministre lundi il a travaillé pendant 33
ans à titre d'ingénieurs et de cadres
supérieurs fait partie des plus gros
joueurs de l'industrie forestière
l'entreprise n'a pas voulu accorder
d'entrevue
ils sont pour la main plus que
majoritaire dans ce sens qu'ils ont quoi
les 50% de de toute l'activité sont les
plus importants dans la province
contrairement au québec et la
colombie-britannique le
nouveau-brunswick n'a pas de système
d'indexation automatique des redevances
pour les entreprises forestières et 600
go et la province n'a pas non plus
l'intention comme l'ont fait l'ontario
et l'alberta de les ajuster de façon
discrétionnaire
pourtant les redevances ont été réduites
lors des crises économiques en 2008 et
2009 déplore les partis de l'opposition
le problème c'est que on ne coupe pas
assez de bois sur le privé sauf une
piste dorian jean-guy comeau est
propriétaire de plus de 320 hectares de
forêt les lots boisés comme un chien
représente 30% des terres exploitables
du nouveau brunswick celle de la
couronne 50% les industriels possède le
reste 20%
on n'est pas trop un missile de postes
avoir des caisses qui se pose c'est quoi
qu'il se passe quelque chose qui se pose
c'est le gouvernement qui travaille pour
des collaborations sigma gouvernement
travaillerait pour moi comme qui
travaillent pour les corporations on
serait pas dans les déficits que nous
avons dans cette province pour regarder
l'argent qui a été perdu un et trois
dernières années pour l'augmentation des
produits de matériaux de construction
est ainsi plus est le prix qu'il reçoit
pour une corde de bois qui sert à
fabriquer du 2 par 4 est moins élevé
qu'il y à 300 140 $ comparativement à
175 en 2018
avez vous l'impression vous vous faites
avoir faire avoir et pas un mot
on a été crucifié les seuls vrais mots
on a été crucifiée par les gouvernements
qu'on a eu depuis ces dates de 80 de ses
dégoûts gouvernement de corporation
regardez où ils viennent et où ils vont
aller après qui sort de la politique
la solution selon monsieur comeau et de
revenir à l'ancien système qui obligeait
la province a négocié avec les
propriétaires comme lui une beauté
incroyable
des fois tenir loin loin loin loin way
verizon du val andré frenette avance une
autre piste
je pense que devrait avoir des gens
formés qui sont à même de venir chez
vous puis de vérifier to work de
s'appeler faciliter la certification du
bois est aussi revitaliser les régions
qui ont fait des ans ont souffert de la
fermeture des petites séries au profit
des comptes joueurs et si mme
montembeault radio-canada batteuse